[Musik]
einen guten Abend liebe Zuschauer es ist
Donnerstagabend und es ist klasse dass
sie wieder mit dabei sind Krieg Klima
Energieknappheit Rezession viele
Menschen zweifeln ob die Politik diese
Krisen in den Griff bekommt manche bit
zweifeln dass sie überhaupt noch
demokratisch zu lösen sind bedroht ist
die Demokratie also von innen aber auch
von außen wir leben in einer Zeitenwende
und genau das macht Menschen Angst von
Politikern erwarten Sie nicht nur die
richtigen Worte zu finden sondern vor
allem das Richtige zu tun wir müssen
reden mit diesen Gästen
Klaus Kleber ZDF-Moderator
Sarah Lee Heinrich Bundesvorsitzende
Grüne Jugend
und der Historikerin Hedwig Richter
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
und die begrüßt sie und die Gäste noch
mal ganz herzlich mit Joachim Gauck dem
Bundespräsidenten ARD sprechen wir in
dieser Sendung auch los geht's Klaus
Kleber Journalist Autor Kollege des ZDF
geschätzter Kollege des ZDF
wir sind mit reichsbürgern sogenannten
reichsbürgern konfrontiert und die
wollen den demokratischen Staat
abschaffen ist das eine reale Gefahr
nein also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass aus diesem Haufen irgendetwas
geordnetes gefährliches für unsere
Ordnung entsteht aber es brauchte ja
auch keine gefährliche Organisation um
Walter Lübcke zu töten das ist eine
polizeiliche Gefahr die mit
polizeilichen Mitteln
kontrolliert werden muss aber dadurch
dass sie den Anspruch erhoben haben dass
sie definieren was unser Staat ist
werden sie jetzt glaube ich auch ein
bisschen zu ernst genommen und ich
kann mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen dass
die eine Gefahr für die öffentliche
Ordnung und in demokratische Ordnung in
Deutschland werden können das war in
Amerika an diesem berüchtigten sechsten
Januar anders mit dem Sturm aufs Kapitel
und das war ja jetzt auch keine keine
Gewalt Entfaltung die von der
amerikanischen Armee und Polizei nicht
hätte beherrscht werden können also
trotzdem macht es einen immer
nachdenklich wenn solche Stimmungen
Auftrieb bekommen aber eine Gefahr für
unser Staatswesen kann ich da nicht
erkennen Hedwig Richter ist bei uns
Historikerin an der Bundeswehr
Universität
Offiziere unterrichten sie lehren sie in
Geschichte wie besorgt macht sie Frau
Richter das tatsächlich bei diesen
reichsbürgern auch Offiziere dabei sind
Soldaten also erstens macht mich das
natürlich besorgt und ich denke schon
wir sollten das ernst nehmen trotz allem
auch wenn das scheinbar nur Verrückte
Typen sind ganz bestimmt sind sie
verrückt aber als sie völkerin würde ich
auf jeden Fall auch darauf hinweisen
dass Rechte ter einfach zur Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik gehört also die ganze
Geschichte ist durchzogen mit rechtem
Terror wir reden sehr sehr viel über die
ERF aber wir sollten nicht übersehen wie
traumatisch dass sich durch die ganze
Geschichte zieht und was die Bundeswehr
betrifft finde ich eigentlich auch sehr
wichtig dass wir überlegen wie schaut
eigentlich die Gesellschaft auf die
Bundeswehr warum kriegen wir es nicht
hin dass die Bundeswehr wirklich
funktioniert das ist ein guter Hinweis
das sollten wir unbedingt tun und haben
Sarah Lee Heinrich bei uns eine der
Sprecherinnen der Grünen Jugend
AktivistInnen der sogenannten letzten
Generationen berufen sich auf einen
Widerstandsrecht auch auf ein
Widerstandsrecht und haben nun parallel
auch Besuch von der Polizei bekommen
ist das ein ein engagierte Jugend oder
ist das auch in ihren Augen ein Protest
der zu weit geht
also ich glaube und ich hoffe dass jetzt
gerade auch nach den Razzien gegen die
Reichsbürger die Vergleiche mit der
Klima RF ein bisschen zur Ruhe kommen
weil es total
unverhältnismäßig war man kann natürlich
immer weiter darüber reden ob man diese
Form des zivilen Ungehorsams strategisch
klug findet für die Sache oder auch
nicht das was mir ein bisschen zu kurz
kommt ist am Ende des Tages sind es auch
viele junge Menschen die bei der letzten
Generation aktiv sind die sind vor allem
gerade verzweifelt weil sie das Gefühl
haben dass sehr viele Krisen aufeinander
kommen jetzt hat man eine Regierung die
gesagt hat das ist jetzt die letzte
Klima Regierung die etwas daran tun kann
und sie reist jedes Klimaziel und da
mache ich mir auch Sorgen um die Zukunft
ich habe auch Angst davor dass es mir
dürren gibt mehr Hunger gibt mehr Kriege
gibt am Ende des Tages und diese
Verzweiflung kann ich sehr gut verstehen
so und dann gibt's trotzdem eine
Opposition Friedrich Merz sagt diese
Razzien sind zu begrüßen hier muss der
Rechtsstaat Zähne zeigen Alexander
Dobrindt Chef der CS der Landesgruppe
sprach eben von einer linken RAF noch
mal die Frage
da finden Straftaten statt das ist
Nötigung das wird jetzt gegebenenfalls
auch Verfahren geben
sehen Sie eine Alternative als dass der
Staat auch damit umgehen muss nach
rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien also die
Menschen die sich bei der letzten
Generation engagieren so wie viele
Menschen die sich im Rahmen vom zivilen
Ungehorsam auch engagiert haben ich habe
ja auch in meiner eigenen Mutterpartei
Menschen die zum Beispiel mit der
Anti-Atom Bewegung da einige Erfahrungen
gemacht haben die wussten auch worauf
sie sich einlassen sie wussten auch dass
sie damit manchmal in Grauzone oder
darüber hinausgehen das ist glaube ich
so die Fragen die sich aber meiner
Meinung nach aus diesem Protest
rauswerfen die müssen wir eigentlich in
der Gesellschaft diskutieren und da
finde ich natürlich komplett
unangemessen wie die CDU sich da verhält
also in Wochen wo wir gerade über
Reichsbürger reden über
eine Klima Erft zu reden das finde ich
total
harmlosen am Ende des Tages und ich
glaube das tut uns nicht gut jenseits
von Straftaten Frau Richter ist ja
vielleicht ganz gut zu fragen wer legt
eigentlich fest wann Protest gut und
wann Protest schlecht ist in einer
Gesellschaft es hat ja auch
Demonstrationen gegen ttip oder gegen
ceta gegeben also wir fragen nach dem
nach der Unzufriedenheit in diese
Demokratie und wollen verstehen was man
ertragen muss vielleicht auch und sogar
gut finden muss und was man aushalten
muss und wo gegen man sich werden muss
ja das wird natürlich immer ausgehandelt
also in der Demokratie gibt es keine
Wahrheit die das festlegt und ich finde
das auch wahnsinnig interessant wie man
auf die letzte Generation reagiert hat
ich fand es auch unglaublich übertrieben
als ich finde diese prozessform auch
nicht besonders sinnvoll aber ich kann
die Jugendlichen gut verstehen und diese
Überreaktion hat glaube ich sehr viele
damit zu tun dass wir den Extremismus
der Normalität nämlich dass wir die
ganze Zeit dabei sind den Planeten zu
zerstören dass man den überschreitet
dass man so tut als ob das Problem diese
letzte Generation sei und eben nicht die
Zerstörung die wir mit unserem
alltäglichen Leben vornehmen ja wir sind
nicht an einem Punkt wo Klaus Kleber
sagte wo an der Demokratie in diesem
Land zu zweifeln ist und der Vergleich
zu Washington und dem Sturm auf das
Kapitol war auch schon in dieser Runde
dennoch die Frage wie und wird eine
Demokratie immer mit einem Knall
zugrunde gehen oder kann sie einfach
auch ganz langsam
wegwimmern sagen Politologen ja das
dieses schöne Zitat ich ich halte mich
mehr an das Zitat dass die Demokratie in
der Dunkelheit stirbt und das deswegen
ein aufklärender Journalismus ganz
wichtig ist das hat ja die Washington
Post nachdem Jeff Bezos sie gekauft und
aufgerüstet hat zu einer wirklich
einflussreichen und nicht vom
Unternehmer Gelenken Zeitung zum Motto
glaube ich gemacht das war er
Dunkelheit können wir uns nicht leer als
die Verzicht auf Streit wir uns nicht
leisten das ist Demokratie definieren
ich war 13 68 ich war kein 68er aber ich
habe aus der Zeit noch sehr gute in
Erinnerung dass wenn man etwas politisch
erreichen will eine richtige Veränderung
erreichen will
dann gehört auch ab und zu Sand ins
Getriebe und das muss ein demokratischer
Staat aushalten dass man die Zufahrt vom
Flughafen zugeklebt ist für ein paar
Stunden
das müssen wir verkraften und dürfen
nicht die revolutionsgarten zur Ordnung
rufen holen die die dann die
Demonstranten wegräumen das gehört sich
nicht das ist unverhältnismäßig auch das
Vokabular war unverhältnismäßig ich
glaube in der Demokratie die
funktioniert und unsere ist eine die
hält auch das aus und wir sind bei der
Frage nach den Ursachen warum so viele
Menschen mit der Demokratie und auch
dieser Gesellschaft unzufrieden sind da
die Heinrich würden Sie sagen 44% letzte
Bertelsmann Studie würden Sie sagen das
hat damit zu tun dass sie nicht
überfordert fühlen das hat damit zu tun
dass es jetzt vielleicht doch drei
Krisen zu viel sind wie fällt ihr Befund
aus
also ich glaube schon dass Demokratien
quasi auch wegwimmern können und das ist
dadurch passiert also wenn ich mir die
letzten Wahlen anschauen die
stattgefunden haben wo immer gut 40
Prozent einfach nicht zur Wahl gegangen
sind dann liegt das nicht daran dass das
Leute sind die blöd sind die das nicht
verstanden haben sondern das sind ganz
viele Menschen die erhoffen sich nicht
mehr dass durch Politik eine Veränderung
stattfindet die in ihrem Sinne ist die
haben erlebt dass sie nicht wirklich
profitiert haben von wohlstandsgewinnen
beispielsweise das sind Menschen die
haben die sind nicht alle haben aber die
haben schon größtenteils Abstiegsängste
und das ist eine Entwicklung die wir
immer weiter beobachten können wenn wir
die Situation haben dass in
Niedersachsen ist nicht mal also
Reichsbürger und die können dann so irre
sein sind das eine aber wenn in
Niedersachsen die AFD eigentlich gar
kein Landesverband hatte und mal aus dem
Nichts zweistellig geworden ist dann hat
das etwas damit zu tun dass wir eine
Verunsicherung haben und ja es kommen
gerade viele Krisen auf uns zu ich
glaube das Problem ist vor allem dass
wir nicht kein Umgang damit gefunden
haben im Sinne von das zu ertragen
sondern wir müssten jetzt was gegen
diese Krisen tun und da finde ich den
Begriff Extremismus der Normalität quasi
gar nicht so schlecht um das zu
beschreiben was machen wir denn wenn die
soziale Spaltung immer weitergibt wenn
es immer mehr Krieg und Krisen gibt und
wenn der Planet anfängt zu brennen quasi
und darauf hat auch die Bundesregierung
gerade nicht wirklich eine Antwort wenn
der Bundeskanzler das Wort von der
Zeitenwende Klaus Kleber in den Mund
nimmt kann das Menschen natürlich auch
Angst machen
weil es für sie bedeutet teurere Energie
höhere Rüstungsausgaben und genau dieses
wohlstandsversprechen kann Verbrechen
dieses wohlstandsversprechen kann nicht
mehr gehalten werden ich finde die diese
Zusammenhänge die Dinge ein bisschen
unterbewertend und das ist auch was was
ich an der an der Debatte im Land sehe
dass dieser 24 Februar jetzt höre
Gaspreise gebracht hätte oder vielleicht
auch die Schere weiter auseinander gehen
lässt
das ist nicht die hauptfolge die
hauptfolge dieses Tages ist dass die
Ordnung in der meine Generation die
erste war die von von ja die die die von
A bis Z ich bin hoffentlich noch nicht
ganz bei Z in Frieden leben durfte diese
Ordnung ist jetzt weggebrochen und das
ist unendlich viel wichtiger und leider
problematischer als der Gaspreis den man
mit von der Zukunft
gebauten Milliarden dann möglicherweise
abpuffern kann und dann wird es eine
Frage der Sozialpolitik die eigentliche
Zeiten wende ich glaube auch dass das
Holz das meinte ich hoffe es jedenfalls
das bezieht sich darauf dass wir eine
ganz andere Art zu leben wieder
einnehmen müssen und das will niemand
also ich will es am wenigsten aber die
Umstände zwingen ist auf und ich sehe
die die Bereitschaft nicht sich auf
diese Herausforderung einzulassen das
wird so ein bisschen weggeblendet in
sozialen
Diskussionen die wir jetzt
sinnvollerweise haben aber das ist nicht
die Hauptsache dahinter steht wirklich
was existenzielles wird unser Modell
sich als Gesellschaft zu organisieren
in einem demokratischen freiheitlichen
Gesellschaft
in dem Aufsteigen dieser autoritären
Systeme und in eine in einer
europäischen Ordnung in der es plötzlich
wieder möglich ist die Nachbarn zu
überfallen und sich imperialistisch
einzuverleiben das werden wir das was
wir eigentlich als Kern unseres Lebens
erlebt haben werden wir das bewahren
können das ist die Frage und welche
Schlussfolgerungen wir daraus ziehen
soll das dann zum Beispiel heißen dass
wir uns genau in dieser Gefahr sehen
dass wir nur noch mit unseren Freunden
Handel treiben dass wir uns sozusagen
auf uns selbst und den besten und die
Demokratie besinnen und wieder
zurückkehren in ein altes Blog denken ja
die Rückkehr im Block denken glaube ich
ich schau die Historikerin an
natürlich eine Gefahr aber ich es ist
auch nicht notwendig da jetzt auf dem
Absatz kehrt zu machen und alles 100%
anders zu machen keinen Handel mehr mit
China zu treiben wäre Unsinn es geht
auch gar nicht ich war neulich auf einer
Tagung und da sagte jemand der der ein
großes deutsches Handelsunternehmen
vertritt als gesagt natürlich können wir
in Zukunft die Jeans in in der Türkei
machen lassen statt in China das geht
fragt man sich wie es mit Erdogans
Türkei ist auch noch mal ein Thema aber
er sagte das Problem wird sein dass die
teurer werden
ja sonst schon jetzt in der Türkei
produzieren das zweite ist man muss ihn
Jeans jetzt wieder an Knöpfe gewöhnen
denn weit über 90% aller Reißverschlüsse
werden hergestellt das wird dann werden
wir wieder auf die angewiesen also Knopf
Jeans sind die Zukunft und wir sind noch
mal bevor wir die größere Frage nach dem
Blöcken Stellen Hedwig Richter bei den
44%, die unzufrieden sind mit der
Demokratie wie fällt ihr Befund aus
woher kommt diese große Zahl von
Menschen die findet und zwar in diesem
Land und vergleichbar auch in anderen
europäischen Ländern die finden dass die
Demokratie nicht ihre Sorgen und
Bedürfnisse befriedigt also da würde ich
gerade mit dem längeren historischen
Blick sagen dass zum Beispiel in 50er
Jahren die Menschen viel viel
zufriedener waren und das waren ja viel
ungleichere Gesellschaften viel
ungerechte ihre Gesellschaften nicht
diverse Gesellschaft und wir würden auch
sagen weniger partizipative weniger
demokratische Gesellschaft und
Unzufriedenheiten am 17 80er Jahre zu
und das war auch eine Zunahme von
Demokratisierung also wir müssen diese
Zahlen ein bisschen differenzierte
betrachten und ich würde auch zuerst mal
sagen dass unsere Demokratie sehr sehr
stabile Demokratie ist und dass die ganz
große Frage jetzt ist wie kriegen wir
eigentlich die Transformation die wir
hinbringen müssen vor allem die
ökologische Transformation wie kriegen
die wir hin und bleiben gleichzeitig
frei also können gleichzeitig unsere
freiheitliche Demokratie erhalten
ausgezeichnet in einer Zeit wo es einen
Krieg gibt das ausgerechnet in einer
Zeit wo es eine Inflation gibt das
ausgerechnet in einer Zeit wo
tatsächlich Milliarden dafür ausgegeben
werden müssen
dass eine verneunfachung von
Energiepreisen aufgehalten wird wo ist
denken Sie dieser überforderungsdruck am
größten oder sind in unser
überforderungssyndrom irgendwie am
meisten ausgeschlagen also ich würde ein
bisschen anders als erkläre sagen dass
es sehr sehr eng zusammengehört also
dass wir diese billige Energie hatten am
hingia mit unserer unrealistischen
Außenpolitik zusammen also Realpolitik
heißt ja noch lange nicht dass sie
realistisch ist und wir haben die in den
in den
Energiepreisen steckte einfach nicht der
der tatsächliche Preis drin und dann mit
den Überforderungen würde ich ganz
wichtig finden dass Politiker
PolitikerInnen viel klarer reden was
Sache ist und dass sie erwachsen reden
mit Menschen also Olaf Scholz der sagt
ähm
never walk alone niemand zurückgelassen
schön und gut aber die Frage ist doch
machen wir das paternalistisch oder
machen wir das partizipativ und an den
Umfragen ja noch ein Punkt finde ich
total interessant dass die Bevölkerung
ja bereit ist also selbst nach vielen
Monaten Krieg war eine große Mehrheit
bereit mehr für Energie zu bezahlen und
dann kann interessanter Punkt weil
ehrlich gesagt das ist auch kritisiert
worden im Sommer das sowohl Robert
Habeck als auch Annalena beerburg vor
sozialen Unruhen gewarnt haben Robert
habe ich das Wort sozialen Frieden den
er in Gefahr sein in den Mund und
Annalena baerbock befürchtete gab
Volksaufstände hat vielleicht sogar die
Politik auch ein
geringeres
gutes Bild von den Leuten in diesem Land
nicht unbedingt es gibt so Grund
Misstrauen vor allem gegenüber den
Deutschen würde ich auch sagen wenn man
die die nicht füttert wenn man den nicht
den SUV vor die Türe stellen dann wird
der gefährlich und dann können und ich
finde es ganz ganz wichtig dass wir dass
man wirklich Klartext redet auch
ExpertInnen
das ist nicht mit diesem Wohlstand
weitergeht und Knöpfe Reißverschluss ist
ein Thema aber das werden noch ganz ganz
andere Themen werden wie und dennoch wie
wichtig Klaus ist gleich dran wie
wichtig ist es auch festzuhalten dass
man eben das auch verloren gegangen ist
zu sagen unseren Kindern wird es mal
besser gehen auch das wird ja also ist
als zukunftsversprechend im Grunde
genommen weg und wir werden vorbereitet
auch von Politikern dieser Regierung
darauf dass es ein weniger geben wird ja
und vor allem das ist auch anders sein
wird also unsere Kinder Enkelkinder
werden ein anderes Leben führen die
Städte müssen ganz ganz anders aussehen
und es kann auch was positives sein also
dass man eben weniger Lärm hat
beispielsweise dass man den recht halt
auf öffentliche Verkehrsmittel und nicht
ein recht drei Autos für die Tür zu
haben und ist umgeben von vielen Straßen
also und da denke ich werde das wirklich
ganz wichtig dass Politik auch die
Chancen gerade Demokratien haben also
gerade Demokratien sind eigentlich in
der Lage Expertenwissen einzuspeisen die
Bevölkerung mitzunehmen den zuzutrauen
entscheidende Punkt ist glaube ich weil
wir gerade über die Bereitschaft zu
Opfern gesprochen haben das wird weit
unterschätzt was Leute bereit sind also
das wenn man auch im Freundeskreis redet
man die Menschen sind nicht habgierig
von von Grund auf und wollen immer nur
ihre Vorteile gesicherte entscheidend
ist dass es gerecht zugeht dass man das
Gefühl hat es geht ja ich gebe auf habe
Opfer zu machen aber die anderen tun es
auch und jeder so viel wie er schultern
kann und nicht mehr so und wenn man das
das zu versprechen ist glaube ich das
entscheidende man darf in der Politik
jetzt nicht so tun und sagen wir haben
eine zeitenwände aber du bist davon
nicht weiter berührt und so weit ist
finanziell ist schicken wird
am Ende des Tages
anschauen also sie haben quasi in dem
Moment wo sie das sondierungspapier
geschrieben haben gesagt aber
Verteilungsfragen spielen hier gar keine
Rolle in allem was wir tun wir nichts
davon anrühren ich bin die größte
Verfechterin von der Aussetzung der
Schuldenbremse aber gerade wird ja auch
jeder Konflikt der auch ein
verteilungskonflikt wäre nämlich zum
Beispiel wirklich richtig krass an die
übergewinner ranzugehen über
vermögensabgaben das spielt ja alles gar
keine Rolle und am Ende des Tages ja
wenn Menschen das Gefühl haben es geht
gerech dazu sie natürlich sind Menschen
nicht hartgierig aber ich kann jeden
verstehen der gerade Mindestlohn bekommt
das Gefühl hat ich komme nicht über die
Runden und dann reden Menschen über
Wohlstandsverluste und man fragt sich so
ja welchen Wohlstand soll ich denn
eigentlich noch verlieren an der stelle
ich habe doch gar nichts mehr und da
würde ich schon sagen also ich glaube
ich bin nicht so ganz optimistisch
vielleicht liegt es auch ähm daran wie
ich in die nächsten Jahre schaue aber
wenn ich mir meinen Freundeskreis
alleine anschaue da kommt gerade keiner
so recht über die Runden dann macht man
sich zusätzlich sorgen ob wir das mit
der Klimakrise hinkriegen oder
beantwortet die Frage im angesichts der
Regierung mit Nein und dann gibt es
immer mehr Krieg und immer mehr Krisen
auf der ganzen Welt und
deswegen ich weiß nicht ich habe schon
das Gefühl dass wir ein bisschen auf der
Stelle treten was so eine
Krisenbewältigung angeht und es ist
schon damit zusammenhängt dass viele
Menschen das Gefühl haben es geht eben
nicht gerecht zu da passieren Dingen
also es passiert zwar Politik aber ich
profitiere nicht davon ich habe auch
erst vor ein paar Wochen durchsteigen
können was mit der gaspreisbremse genau
passiert und ich glaube manche also klar
Politik sollte klarer kommunizieren aber
manche Dinge die man schlecht tut kann
man nicht besser kommunizieren ich
glaube auch noch ein Statement zur
Gartenlage hätte sie nicht besser
gemacht am Ende des Tages sondern das
war schlecht gemacht die berühmte
personlage wo man darüber stritt die
Preise zu erhöhen in einer Zeit in der
sich eigentlich alle wünschen dass sie
runtergehen wir haben heute am frühen
Abend mit dem Bundespräsidenten ARD
Joachim Gauck sprechen können zu genau
diesen Fragen mit welchen Ängsten sich
die Gesellschaft befasst wie groß eine
spaltungsgefahr ist und welche Feinde
die Demokratie hat
die Demokratie ist kein Supermarkt sagen
manche Politiker gerne jetzt könnte man
behaupten das ist sie doch und könnte
böse sagen man kann sogar Politiker
kaufen
wie schlimm ist das was da in Brüssel
passiert ist schlimm genug also solange
es eine kleine Minderheit ist ist es
entsetzlich aber keine Katastrophe es
ist so
in allen möglichen Bereichen agieren
eben nicht nur vollkommene oder
anständige Menschen es gibt immer auch
ein Zug nach oben für die die Egoisten
sind und super Egoisten oder die
manchmal sogar kriminell sind und die
Vermögen ist zu tarnen und lange kriegt
sie Öffentlichkeit nicht mit wohl dem
Land das eine freie Presse hat ja wir
kennen genug Länder wo das nicht möglich
ist wo solche Typen auf Dauer regieren
nun sagen sie oder sagten im Sommer wir
können auch einmal ein bisschen frieren
für die Freiheit brauchen die Bürger in
diesem Moment und in der Situation in
der wir sind solche Predigten zum
Verzicht brauchen Sie den Hinweis dass
es auch den Waschlappen gibt brauchen
Sie den Hinweis dass man zwei Minuten
duschen kann und was macht es mit so
einer Nachricht die parallel
predigen und Wein trinken das ist so
aber wenn wir jetzt an einen konkreten
Politikertypus denken zum Beispiel den
mit dem Waschlappen ja das ist eine
ehrenwerte Politiker und der ist nicht
deshalb weniger wert weil es in Brüssel
Typen gibt die sich haben kaufen lassen
also wir wollen mal die Kirche im Dorf
lassen bei der Beurteilung unserer
unseres politischen Personals und sagen
also das haben wir noch im Griff und wir
haben Instanzen Institutionen aber auch
die Medien und die Zivilgesellschaft die
achten schon drauf dass da dann
eine umkehrende Wende passiert oder auch
eine Bestrafung je nachdem was angezeigt
ist und manchmal erledigt sich das
einfach durch die öffentliche Meinung
die sich im Netz oder in den Medien dann
darstellt und dann gibt es Rücktritte
und das ist okay aber manchmal muss man
den Leuten auch nicht sagen was die von
selber tun also Menschen die
verantwortungsbewusst leben die haben
schon automatisch gewusst was die
Hautärzte sowieso sagen man brauchen
nicht jeden Tag einen oder zweimal
Duschen das ist überhaupt nicht
erforderlich und in bestimmten
Konfliktsituationen regelt sich vieles
von selber ist es aber auch nicht
schlimm wenn ein Politiker mal einen
kleinen Hinweis gibt Leute nicht
durchdrehen sondern
ihr könnt selber mehr tun als ihr im
Moment tut auch der aktuelle
Bundespräsident Herr Gauck fordert
Widerstandskraft gegen die Feinde der
Demokratie verbrauchen ganz viele
Menschen in diesem Land momentan ihre
Kraft nicht um überhaupt über den Monat
zu kommen
ja es gibt solche Menschen aber ich habe
schon im Frühjahr und Frühsommer als
sehr viel in den Medien zu lesen weil
wie schlecht es uns gehen würde wie wir
frieren würde das hat uns ja monatelang
beschäftigt jetzt ist Winter wir frieren
nicht und unsere Speicher sind
nennenswertvoll und zudem hat das
passiert ist das passiert was ich gesagt
habe das ist ja kein Land der Kälte und
wir haben gerade für den Bereich den Sie
angesprochen haben eine Fülle von
Entscheidungen der Regierung gesehen um
die Menschen zu stützen gerade die dies
brauchen es gibt sogar Geld für die die
es nicht brauchen ich vermute ich kriege
auch noch 300 Euro aber der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister über eine
gasumlage gesprochen und zwar über viele
über viele Wochen die hätte die Preise
sogar erhöht die Regierung tut jetzt das
glatte Gegenteil sie hat verstanden dass
sie die Energiepreise senken muss weil
sie sich von neunfacht haben in den
Briefen die die Versorger schreiben hat
die Regierung zu spät reagiert
das werden wir haben wir häufiger
gesehen und das sehen wir häufiger es
gibt eben Politiker die haben einen Stil
der sie ihre starken Prinzipien benennen
und unabhängig von dem was gerade
passiert wird dann irgendein Prinzip
durchgedrückt hier hat sich in den
letzten Jahrzehnten eigentlich
herausgestellt dass wir so reagieren auf
die aktuellen lagen die sogenannte auf
Sicht fahren und das hat die
Bundeskanzlerin häufig gemacht und unser
jetziger Bundeskanzler hat hat dies auch
zum Teil übernommen gleichwohl aber
deutliche Entscheidung getroffen und
sehr früh signalisiert wir lassen euch
nicht im Stich und da wird es immer noch
Leute geben wir haben das jetzt gesehen
bei der Heizkosten Unterstützung sie hat
einfach noch welche die waren nicht
unterstützen na ja dann hat seine Zeit
gedauert dann wurden die die mit
pelletszeiten auch noch mal bitte wenn
sogar der Rat der Wirtschaftsweise
möchte noch mal ganz kurz auf die
Gerechtigkeit kommen wenn sogar
Wirtschaftsweisen sagt dass über diese
anderthalb Jahre die Reichen mehr zur
Kasse gebeten werden könnten weil
es gibt Menschen die merken überhaupt
gar nicht das was teuer wird oder es tut
ihnen nicht weh warum geht dann eine
Bundesregierung darauf nicht ein warum
traut sie sich nicht also erstens ich
habe das in meiner eigenen Familie ich
war früher Arm und gehörte jetzt zu
denen die also für die das kein Problem
ist weil ich finanziell so ausgestattet
bin wie ich bin und gleichzeitig habe
ich in der eigenen Familie Menschen die
das genauso geht die eben voller Sorge
auf das Monatsende schauen und sehr
dankbar sind dass unser Staat Abfederung
macht und das ist ja wir brauchen oft
lange um
zu erkennen wo ist jetzt eigentlich die
Hilfe nötig und wo muss es schneller
gehen wir haben auch ein Land in dem wir
eine überbordende Bürokratie haben und
dann sind erstens die politischen
Auseinandersetzungen da sie schauen Sie
in unsere Koalition da sind sehr
unterschiedliche Politikansätze
miteinander verbunden und müssen sich
helfen gegenseitig zu regieren wir
wollen hoffen dass sie sich nicht
hindern gegenseitig sondern helfen sich
ja noch und dann dauert es eben bis es
aus äh gesprochen ist und natürlich
manchmal ja sehr kurzfrist ja woher
kommen denken sie ganz grundsätzlich die
Frustration und auch das Misstrauen in
Politik das sind keine schönen Zahlen
44% der Menschen sind grundsätzlich
nicht zufrieden mit dem was die
demokratische Gesellschaft Ihnen hier
ermöglicht in diesem Land woher kommt
das wenn nicht aus auch einer sozialen
und ökonomischen
in Deutschland und Skandinavien und in
der Schweiz kommt das Protest Potenzial
nicht auf die Straße wegen sozialer
Dinge das ist eine Minderheit sondern es
ist eine kulturelle Verunsicherung und
auch eine politische Verunsicherung die
viele Menschen in Europa und nicht und
darüber hinaus erfasst hat und das hängt
damit zu sein dass eine Fülle von
veränderungsfaktoren Menschen in Angst
versetzen also es gibt die altbekannten
Dinge die Menschen Probleme machen
Globalisierung Entgrenzung durch die
Europäisierung dann gibt es diese
sagenhafte Entwicklung in der in im
technologischen Bereich mit der
Verunsicherung die durch künstliche
Intelligenz und für die ganze
nachrichtentechnologie da ist manche
fragen sich dann ja werden wir uns noch
später selber entscheiden können oder
sind die Algorithmen mächtiger als unser
freier Wille dann gibt's die großen
Krisen also die Klimakrise dann war es
eine Finanzkrise dann gibt's die
migrationskrise oder den
Migrationswellen die viel
empfinden und wenn sie die Staaten
angucken in denen die sozialen Probleme
eigentlich geregelt sind Skandinavien
etwa oder hier auch in Mitteleuropa dann
haben die Angst vor genau diesen
Prozessen vor dieser Modernisierung
letztlich Angst vor der Moderne und vor
der offenen Gesellschaft auch dass wir
alles so lange miteinander besprechen
wie wir das tun ja wir sind nun mal
vielfältig und dann brauchen wir
diskussions- und manchmal auch
streiträume in denen sich abklärt was
soll der nächste Politik Schritt sein
und ein bestimmter Teil der Bevölkerung
ich habe mich damit länger befasst weil
ich aufgrund eines eines Buches dass ich
gemacht habe mal geforscht hat wie setze
ich eigentlich so eine Gesellschaft
zusammen woher kommen diese massiven
Ängste und bin auf Studien gestoßen die
belegen dass in 28 europäisch
untersuchten Ländern nach der die
Jahrtausendwende 33% der Menschen so
stark extrem konservativ Struktur
konservativ geprägt und das die
britische Prägung und für solche
Menschen sind Entwicklungsphasen in
denen sich sehr viel verändert Angst
machen und Angst darüber sollten wir
heute noch mal sprechen Angst ist immer
eine große Zeit für Populisten und eine
schwierige Zeit für rationale Politik so
und dann daher kommen diese diese
Bündnisse von hoch unterschiedlichen
Menschen die aus unterschiedlichen
Gründen unsere liberale offene
Gesellschaft nicht mögen die überfordert
sie und die einen haben die für soziale
Gründe und die anderen sagen ja Merkel
will ja die Bevölkerung austauschen da
sind es kulturelle Ängste das gilt zum
Beispiel für ganz Skandinavien da würden
sie da gibt es auch ein paar arme aber
da ist im Grunde eine befriedete soziale
Landschaft und da ist es sehr stark
angetriggert diese Angst durch diese
zuwanderungsströme und die kulturellen
Veränderungen die dann den Teil der
Bevölkerung der so strukturiert ist dass
er sich erstmal fürchtet und dann schaut
für den ist das
Partei die anders ist als die
herkömmlichen und dann findet man am
rechten Rand irgendwelche die dann schon
diese Ängste aufnehmen und damit
retropolitik betreiben
darüber und über Angela Merkel
sogenannte Reichsbürger planten nun
offenbar einen Putsch Herr Gauck der
größte Feind der Demokratie steht rechts
ja das ändert sich manchmal manchmal
steht der rechts und das ist hier im
Moment so ganz eindeutig und ich bin ein
Mensch und als Bürger und Politiker der
sagt ich will eine Demokratie die sich
wehrt und die nicht einfach abwartet und
zuschauen und insofern kann ich damit
umgehen dass diesen merkwürdigen
verfassungsverhalten einmal ihre Grenzen
aufgewiesen werden wir haben ja sehr
lange zugeschaut und du musst auch als
liberale Demokratie lange zuschauen also
wir leben nicht nur mit Menschen
zusammen die werden wir teilen und die
dürfen das auch die dürfen auch dumm
bleiben wenn sie das wollen und das
müssen wir kann aber wir müssen nicht
ertragen wenn sie ganz grundsätzlich
unsere Verfassung ergeben und dann noch
an mit Waffen vielleicht sogar Menschen
bedrohen man kann sie trotzdem jetzt
Spinner nennen und muss dann aber sie
nicht sagen
machen wenn sie doch aus der Justiz und
aus den Schulen und gar aus dem Militär
also aus der Bundes
warum sollen wir uns Sorgen machen wenn
drei vier Figuren aus den akademischen
Kreisen dazu gehören das ist schon immer
so gewesen in der Geschichte ja auch
Linien hatte studiert ja und in der der
klügste aller Juristen in Deutschland
der der Adolf Hitler unterstützt hat
Karl Schmidt war gerade so ein Genie in
seinem Fach also sie werden niemals eine
Bewegung haben die nur als Tölpeln
besteht sondern es wird immer eine
intellektuelle Begleitung alle möglichen
wirkköpfe geben und das sehen wir auch
hier und das ist unmöglich dass wir wenn
eine Richterin dort mitmacht oder 13
Figuren aus dem militärischen Bereich
dass wir dann sagen na ja das das ist ja
nun schon in der Mitte der Gesellschaft
angekommen das ist einfach Unfug weil
ich der Räder Realität nicht entspricht
denn wir haben wirklich und das merken
wir wenn wir uns vergleichen mit der
Zeit der Weimarer Republik Wärme eine
überaus stabile Mitte das merken wir im
Wahlverhalten und wir merken als an der
Kraft unserer Zivilgesellschaft aber es
sind insgesamt 23.000
Menschen beteiligt in diesen
reichsbürgern die der Verfassungsschutz
zählt da sagen auch viele das ist nur
die Oberfläche und man solle nicht
unterschätzen wie eng und wie intensiv
und effektiv die Drähte eben auch in
eine Neonaziszene hinein ist ich möchte
nach den klimakläbern Fragen
ganz anderes ja keine Bedrohung der
Gesellschaft das Protest und auch da
wird bekommen die Besuch von der Polizei
es ist korrekt wenn der Chef der
CSU-Landesgruppe Alexander Dobrindt von
einer linken sprechen
und ich kann ihm da auch in keiner Weise
zu spielen also das ist ja ähm wird ja
mit Kanonen auf Spatzen geschossen man
darf diese Menschen ruhig kritisieren
das geschieht auch und man darf sie auch
wegen einer falschen Strategie
kritisieren schauen sie werden über 80%
der Menschen die hier leben diese
Funktion nicht gut finden wobei 60
Prozent die Anliegen gut finden dann ist
offensichtlich die Strategie wenig
geeignet um Sympathien zu erwerben in
der breiteren Bevölkerung und deshalb
ist es kritikwürdig aber auch einem
anderen Grund ich darf nicht als
Einzelner oder Gruppe mit einer
speziellen Moral ausgestattet sagen
meine Moral ist wichtiger als die Normen
unser Recht und auch unser Ordnungsrecht
das geht nicht da das ist eine
gefährliche Entscheidung die persönliche
Moral über das zu stellen was das
Gemeinwesen gesetzlich normiert hat dann
werden wir das akzeptieren würden würden
immer neue Kräfte sich auf ihre
Erkenntnisse auf ihre moralischen
Vorstellungen berufen und sie müssen
sich nur mal ausmalen wenn die nächste
Gruppe die tierschütze nein den Tieren
geht es so schlecht und die Mäuse und
Ratten in unserem Versuch das wollen wir
nicht wir kleben auch dann kommen eine
andere Gruppe die auch grundhalt zu
protestieren das sind die Menschen die
gegen Abtreibungen sind die das nicht
ertragen dass das dass Frauen in einer
Situation in der sie vielleicht Sorgen
haben aber auch sonst dass sie einfach
Abtreibung da sind sie dagegen und sagen
Lebensschutz wenn die jetzt auch
anfangen sich anzugeben dann würden als
nächstes vielleicht die frustrierten
Anhänger einer Fußballmannschaft sagen
das ist so schlimm die Verhältnisse so
schlimm wir kleben als einen
stadienturen fest also ich kann das
jetzt alleine und wir haben das zu einem
Verfassungsrang erhoben aber sie haben
schon gesagt dass zu Erreichung eines
Zieles das und sogar wichtig ist eben
dennoch natürlich nicht Dinge getan
werden dürfen die Strafe wert sind ja
Nötigung ja zum Beispiel Nötigung und
einmal ist es in Ordnung ich habe eben
ja auch stark von der Sinnhaftigkeit
hier argumentiert aber es ist eben auch
eine Frage respektieren wir die Ordnung
die wir uns auf dem problematische Weise
gegeben haben oder fangen wir an
aufgrund unserer persönlichen
Einstellung oder unsere ethischen Normen
die wir haben fangen wir an eine
spezialberechtigung für
normüberschreitendes Handeln zu gewähren
und da das ist eine Gefährdung der
Demokratie sie ist völlig anders als das
worüber wir eben geredet haben aber mit
kleinen
Unachtsamkeiten gegenüber dem Recht
fängt die da beginnt dieser abschüssige
Ebene wo du alles relativieren kannst
und schließlich sagt überhaupt brauchen
wir den Rechtsstaat wissen Sie ich komme
aus der DDR da brauchten die Regierenden
keinen Rechtsstaat sie haben das Recht
zwar gehabt sie hatten auch ein recht
aber die Macht konnte immer durchgreifen
und da ist eine Gefährdung des Rechtes
von oben und wenn Protestgruppen das
Recht von unten angreifen und anknabbern
oder einfach lächerlich machen dann
müssen wir auch sagen Leute euer
Anliegen okay aber so geht's nicht und
ich
wir werden nicht sehen dass die ganze
Bewegung Fridays for future dass die
diese Protestform übernimmt weil dann
würden sie ja den ganzen Respekt den sie
sich erworben haben wieder verlieren und
wir gerade der älteren für mich so als
als großvatertyp ist das doch total
schön zu sehen wenn Leute die Jungs sind
und am liebsten den ganzen Tag an ihrem
Dattel Ding darum Datteln wenn die
plötzlich sagen ich fühle mich
verantwortlich ich gehe mal auf die
Straße hört mal gehalten habt ihr was
vergessen oder oder wie und dann schlägt
mein Herz plötzlich unser Ohr das ist
die Kinder und Jungs die Waffen und
Mädchen die waren da plötzlich auf und
erklären uns wir fühlen uns zuständig
und dies wir fühlen uns zuständig das
kann man auch übertreiben indem man dann
zur Revolution gegenüber dem rechtssta
aufruft oder den rechts statt blamiert
oder lächerlich macht und das sollten
wir dann nicht tun wie viel Anteil hat
die Union ich muss unbedingt auf die
Zuwanderung noch mal kommen wie viel
Anteil haben CDU und CSU herrgau
diese Angst vor dem Fremden von dem sie
sprachen vor der über fremdung wir
brauchen jetzt in diesem Land etwas ganz
außerordentlich Arbeitskräfte nämlich
und es ist völlig klar dass die aus
anderen Kulturen kommen und aus anderen
Ländern das sind 600.000 die wir pro
Jahr brauchen also
wie groß ist der Anteil ist die Frage ja
aber sie haben ja eine parteienfamilien
genannt die CDU und CSU das ist ja bei
dieser Frage gar nicht unser Problem
sondern das Problem sind die AFD Leute
oder die die AFD wählen die haben noch
nicht reagiert aber bei der Union noch
keinen Einwanderungsgesetz ja bei der ja
also ich bin seit langem der Ansicht
gewesen dass das ein einfachen Russland
in ist in dem wir leben aber die Politik
hatte da die von Ihnen vorhin genannten
verzögerungselemente und dafür ist eine
konservative Partei dann auch eher
zuständig die konservative Partei ist
auch in diesem Fall insofern zuständig
und das sehen Sie wenn Sie ich nehme
noch mal weil um von den Ossis
wegzukommen bei der Entwicklung in
Skandinavien es kann Situationen geben
wenn wir zu leger sind bei dem Thema
Zuwanderung dass in der Gesellschaft ein
Kippmoment entsteht wo so viel
Widerstand gegen eine öffnende Politik
ist die alle willkommen heißt dass dann
die Gefahr ist das wirklich extreme an
die Macht kommen und nicht nur ein
bisschen mitregieren dürfen wie zurzeit
die Unterstützung durch die der Schweden
Demokraten für eine moderater Regierung
und sie sehen an dem an der Entwicklung
etwa im in Dänemark und seinem
Nachbarland das plötzlich die
Sozialdemokraten Themenbereiche
Übernehmen von Rechtsaußen das heißt
plötzlich erkennt eine
sozialdemokratische Regierungschefin ich
brauche für meine Politik Mehrheiten im
Land und wenn ich diese Mehrheiten
verliere dann ist das für dieses Land
nicht gut und übernimmt dann sorgen die
immer nur von uns geschoben haben weil
wir zu fortschrittlich zu lieb zu
anständig sind um auch
Zuzüge zu kontrollieren und zu begrenzen
Friedrich Merz erinnern sie sprach von
sozialtourismus
ist es unmöglich Menschen die aus der
Ukraine mit den Gründen die wir doch
alle sehen vor Augen da einzustufen in
dieser Rubrik und greifen wir noch mal
zu Angela Merkel würden Sie denn mit
großer Sorge vor der Erstarkung der AFD
würden Sie denn sagen dass die Politik
von Angela Merkel 2015 schuld daran war
dass die AFD so stark geworden ist wir
haben vorhin nein das würde ich so nicht
sagen aber
es gibt ein Element was mich seinerzeit
als Präsident veranlasst hat zu sagen
unser Herz ist weit aber unsere
Möglichkeiten sind endlich ich habe eben
versucht im Blick auf Skandinavien mal
zu beschreiben was die politische Klasse
dabei beachten muss das kann also auch
durchaus nicht unethisch sein wenn ich
über Begrenzung spreche und über das
Leistungsvermögen einer einer
Gesellschaft deshalb brauchen wir einen
offenen Debatte darüber und Angela
Merkels Wort wir schaffen das war damals
total richtig denn ich möchte doch keine
Regierungschefin haben die sagt Liebe
Landsleute das schaffen wir nicht ja was
soll das das kann sich ja niemand
wünschen was dann vielen Menschen im
Land gefehlt hat ist die klare
Entscheidung wie wir das schaffen und
auf welche Weise wir dieses Problem
angehen ja und das hat sich dann
schrittweise durchaus entwickelt so dass
im Grunde das Land dann ja nicht
hysterisch wurde was rechts
hysterische Wellen und dann Protest auf
der Straße damit sich alles in ihrer
Richtung ändert und das richtige umgehen
sie sprachen von die Union an ist im
Grunde den Teil der Bevölkerung
einzubeziehen der sich vor Wandel
fürchtet auch vor Kult der kultureller
Veränderung und der richtige Weg ist
dann der den sie gewesen haben Leute ist
es rational uns abzuschotten wo bleiben
wir denn ist der deutsche Menschen
überhaupt noch im Stande Erdbeeren zu
pflücken und Spargel zu stechen nein der
deutsche Mensch hat Rücken er kann das
nicht mehr schon allein aus diesem
Grunde oder ist der deutsche Mensch noch
im Stande die Eltern und Großeltern zu
pflegen nein er kann es nicht wir
brauchen Zuzug und so erkennen wir dass
es eine ökonomische Rat zu gibt und
daneben gibt es die humaneration dass
wir Menschen die in Not sind nicht
einfach ja zum Beispiel Ukraine wir
wollen und müssen unbedingt noch auf
diesen Krieg schauen auf furchtbaren
Krieg Herr Gauck Putin hält den Westen
für verweichlicht und prinzipienlos
befürchten auch Sie dass wir früher
aufgeben als er
das kann man schon befürchten weil man
historische Beispiele hat Adolf Hitler
hat auch gedacht der Westen ist so
weicher und die Engländer sind sowieso
so dekadent da kann man kann ja mal
seine Abenteuer machen indem er mit der
Tschechoslowakei anfing und dann sich
Richtung Polen wendete naja die sind ja
sowieso verweichlicht und dann erlebte
er dass das anders war als seine
Vorstellungswelt sich das Ausmalen
konnte also sie sind gute Hoffnung ich
bin ich ich kann nicht hoffnungslos sein
das gehört zu meiner Art zu leben sie
würden notfalls auch eine Waffe in die
Hand nehmen Interview gesagt weil es
mich aufregte das ist eine Reihe von
Menschen gibt die meinen mit einem
Pazifismus im politischen Raum könnten
wir alle Probleme reden und dann habe
ich mir vorgestellt was das für das
bedeutet hat wo Jungs und Männer einfach
abgeknallt worden sind als wären sie im
Schlacht wie oder wie in R wo wo wo wo
wir mit wenig Truppen hätten eingreifen
können und einen Völkermord verhindern
und deshalb muss ein anständiger
friedliebender Bürger irgendwann
begreifen es gibt Situationen wo
zuschauen und gut zureden nicht helfen
sondern wo eine größere Kraft und
Entschiedenheit auf den Tisch gehörten
auf die Agenda gehört und wenn eine
Gesellschaft das nicht begreift dann
sehe ich tatsächlich keine Zukunft und
Putin wird sich verrechnen es wird in
unserer in dieser befriedeten Landschaft
und in dieser ja irgendwie auch
verwöhnten Landschaft weil wir alle ja
Krieg nicht mehr kennen außer meiner
Generation ein bisschen und da wird
wieder ein Bewusstsein entstehen das was
uns am Herzen liegt das haben wir auch
zu schützen und notfalls mit der Waffe
der Bundeskanzler dafür zu lange
gebraucht Joachim
Bundeskanzler zu lange gebraucht bis
diese Waffen lieferten in aller
Konsequenz bis wir dachten dass wir und
überzeugt dachten dass wir unbedingt die
Ukraine unterstützen müssen in diesem
Kampf jetzt wollen wir ihn erstmal loben
also
sondern der Tatsachen wegen denn so
schnell nach dem dieser widerlichen
Aggression durch Putin sich vor den
Deutschen Bundestag zu stellen und eine
Rede zu halten von der ich nicht weiß
welche Person es eigentlich noch
gehalten hätte diese Rede aus welchen
politischen Lage aber wir unter wir
unterstreichen noch mal das ist genug
Ukraine gibt die bis heute sagen jetzt
kommen wir schneller geliefert jetzt
kommen wir zu uns zwei sie haben doch
mich vorhin angesprochen darauf dass
alles so langsam geht
verglichen mit der Langsamkeit die wir
gewöhnt sind ist die Aktivität der
Bundesregierung in diesem Fall eher
günstig zu beurteilen für mich dürfte es
schneller gehen und für einen Großteil
der Menschen in Deutschland auch nicht
für alle für alle Ukraine dürfte es
schneller gehen alle Ukraine sind die
Opfer eines verbrecherischen Überfalls
eines Krieges den sie nicht provoziert
haben deshalb gehört es sich diesen
Menschen beizustehen und jeder der
nachdenkt glaubt dem Kanzler glaubt
Präsident macron dass wir nicht
Kriegspartei werden wollen aber wir
haben gesehen dass eine Ansage der
Zeiten wenn du ein Bewusstsein unser
Bundespräsident hat sogar von der
Existenz des Bösen gesprochen das ist
eine Kategorie die sonst im politischen
Diskurs eher selten vorkommt aber wenn
du so klar Feindschaft erkennst
dann muss auch müssen Entscheidungen
folgen und deshalb gehört zu einer
Ansage der Zeitenwende eine Politik der
Zeitenwende und sie sprechen mich gerade
darauf an wie empfinde ich das und ich
empfinde das so wir haben uns
entschlossen kraftvolle und wirksame
Systeme zu liefern die Panzerhaubitze
die wir liefern das ist ein Ding die ist
noch ein bisschen gefährlich ja als ein
Panzer den wir liefern könnten und die
Abwehrsysteme die wir jetzt eben helfen
den Ukraine aber das Elend ist so groß
und diese unverschämte Aggression
gegenüber Familien und ganz normalen
Menschen indem man die Infrastruktur
zerstört die Leute frieren lässt dabei
oder hungern lässt das Licht ausmisten
das ist alles so widerwärtig dass wir
mehr tun müssen wir haben die
Verpflichtung und nicht nur aus
moralischen Gründen sondern die
verteidigen dort das was wir leben also
wir haben das zu tun okay und er wird es
tun
Punkt
[Gelächter]
Bundespräsident danke fürs Gespräch
Joachim Gauck
ja und wir sind zurück in der Runde
Sarah Lee Heinrich wir verteidigen dort
was wir hier leben also unsere Werte
brauchen wir noch mehr Waffen wie auch
omidoripuls sagt und ihr Kollege Anton
Hofreiter müssen noch mehr Waffen in die
Ukraine der kriegte in der Ukraine
stattfindet das wirklich wirklich
schrecklich und
ganz viel wurde ja am Anfang darüber
geredet dass gerade auch eine junge
Generation sehr lange keinen Krieg mehr
in der Nähe erlebt hat bestimmt nicht
für alle jungen Menschen natürlich in
Deutschland weil wir zum Beispiel auch
viele junge Menschen haben die zum
Beispiel geflüchtet sind hier hin und
trotzdem ist es natürlich total
schockieren und deswegen ist es total
richtig die Ukraine zu unterstützen es
ist aber auch wichtig die Ukraine nicht
nur auf dem Waffen weg zu unterstützen
über Fragen von Wiederaufbau zu reden
der nicht nur so stattfinden sollte dass
es dann quasi so passt das gut für den
Markt ist sondern am Ende des Tages auch
gut für die Menschen dass die Menschen
dort auch leben können wenn Sie wollen
und das ist eben auch viel Unterstützung
gibt wenn wir die Frage von Flucht reden
da fand ich die Debatten in den letzten
Wochen also Herr gaukatja gesagt erhofft
es tut der CDU leid dass sie von
sozialtourismus geredet haben ich hoffe
auch dass es ihnen leid tut dass sie
davon geredet haben das sind genau ja
genau zurückgenommen wieder angefangen
zurückgenommen wieder angefangen und das
ist etwas was mir sehr sehr viel Sorge
bereitet weil da fängt das ja an dass
man dann anfängt doch so leicht nach
außen zu treten quasi doch noch mal
aufzumachen Menschen hier sind besorgt
sie machen sich Sorgen keine Ahnung
Eltern machen sich Sorgen ist genug
Platz für die ganzen Kinder in der
Schule dann machen sich Menschen Sorgen
wie soll ich meine Rechnung bezahlen und
dann kann natürlich solche Sätze wie
rund um die sozialtourismus Debatte
natürlich ein feuerfachen und das war
glaube ich sehr sehr unpassend und hat
gar nichts mit Solidarität für die
Ukraine zu tun er hat es glaube ich
innerhalb von Stunden zurückgenommen und
sich dafür entschuldigt ja und jetzt
wieder eine neue Debatte über die bösen
geflüchteten angefangen wir sind bei wir
wollten ja so gerne noch mal nach
zu der Ukraine schauen und sind
vielleicht noch mal eben nicht bei den
inneren Feinden sondern unseren äußeren
wenn wir da Hedwig Richter auch unsere
Werte verteidigen ist das ein Krieg den
wir auch deshalb im Grunde
ja sehr intensiv unterstützen wir bilden
Soldaten aus wir schicken unsere Waffen
dahin unsere Nachrichtendienste sind da
präsent ist das haben diejenigen Recht
die sagen es ist im Grunde ein
Stellvertreterkrieg nein das finde ich
wirklich zynisch das zu sagen also die
Ukraine wurde brutal überfallen und so
zu tun als ob die USA da irgendwie
eigentlich hintergründig und
heimtückischen Krieg angezeigt hätte das
ist absolut sinnig also das ist wirklich
verschwörungstheoretisch das würde ich
überhaupt nicht sagen und ich würde auch
sagen wir haben alle Gründe und sehr
gute Gründe
Waffen zu liefern die Ukraine zu
unterstützen geflüchtete aufzunehmen und
so weiter weil es tatsächlich auch um
unsere Werte geht weil die Ukraine auch
für uns kämpfen und wir sind Klaus
Kleber wenn man man sich das anschaut
beim Ende des Krieges aber sicherlich in
einer Situation wo Washington auf jeden
Fall ein Wort mitreden wird also es wird
ja immer gesagt das geht nicht ohne die
Ukraine zu entscheiden aber wann wenn
ich jetzt sind die Ukrainer so sehr
abhängig von dem was der besten tut und
was vor allen Dingen die USA tun ja und
deshalb ich habe ich die Befürchtung
dass wenn es jetzt schwieriger wird sich
doch die Stimmen Regen werden die sagen
wir müssen jetzt diese Sache irgendwie
zu Ende bringen und dann muss die
Ukraine auch mal klein beigeben und dann
fängt von fängt man von außen an der
Ukraine zu sagen was sie ertragen muss
damit dieses Friedensangebot oder die
Bereitschaft dann irgendwie zum
Waffenstillstand zu kommen aus Moskau
befriedigt werden kann so und dann
fangen wir an den Ukrainern und
Ukrainerinnen zu sagen also diese fünf
Oblaste müsste jetzt aufgeben und die
das müsste ganz vergessen und in eurem
Parlament müsst ihr jetzt auch einige
Sachen unter Aufsicht von Moskau stellen
oder was auch immer und diese Debatte
könnte unter dem Druck beginnen und
dagegen muss man sich wehren gibt es und
das ist die Frage was ist denn der
Maßstab für Waffenlieferung das haben
auch Sie jetzt gerade nicht um tanzt das
ist die natürliche sehr schön wenn man
auch das Land aufbauen kann und dann die
Menschen denkt und so weiter das alles
richtig was ist aber keine Antwort auf
die Frage was ist unser Maßstab für
militärische Unterstützung das hat nie
jemand beantwortet was ist das Ziel das
verteidigen zu können eigentlich hat die
US-amerikanische Regierung auch von
Anfang an gesagt die Ukraine soll eben
nicht russisches Territorium angreifen
können aber wie kann man jemanden wie
kann man jemanden im untersagen einen
Aggressor zurückzuweisen natürlich auch
auf dessen Gebiet und nicht nur auf
ukrainischen Gebieten also ich will
jetzt gar nicht so Linien kommen aber
die die ich glaube das war die finnische
Ministerpräsidentin wie gesagt hat
Frieden ist möglich wenn die russischen
Truppen ukrainisches Gelände verlassen
waren so das ist meine Ansage das habe
ich von Berlin nicht gehört weil das
wahrscheinlich schwierig ist
auch ähnlich gesprochen der setzt aber
auch seine Worte sehr sorgfältig weil er
natürlich auch um Himmel verwalten will
genau das zu machen was man überhaupt
und das schon begonnen hätte nämlich
eigentlich ein Krieg zwischen USA und
Russland und Putin sagt das ja andauernd
auch jetzt wieder dass er sagt wir haben
deswegen Schwierigkeiten und keine weil
wir gegen den gesamten Westen Krieg
führen müssen hier das ist natürlich
absurd das hat mit der Realität
überhaupt nichts zu tun und trotzdem ist
es gefährlich und wenn man also von
russischen Sicherheitsinteressen spricht
ja
waren und
darf nicht gedemütigt werden und so und
ist das genau die Gefahr dass wir früher
aufgeben dass der Westen früher aufgibt
als Putin aufgeben wird ja trotzdem
finde ich eigentlich diese diese
durchmischten Rollen das irgendwo im
Westen auch jemand ist wie macron der
vielleicht eher in der Lage ist seinen
Anruf in Moskau zu platzieren als jetzt
Joe Biden ist dann irgendwo dazwischen
der deutsche Kanzler im Moment finde ich
diese Orchestrierung eigentlich ganz
ganz ganz gut gemacht denn wir wollen
alle nicht dass das letztendlich nur
durch Waffen entschieden wird denn das
wäre zu grausam und so schlimm es wird
am Ende in der Verhandlung sein müssen